good morning John it's Friday January
19th I was inspired by your little walk
around Manhattan in the morning so I
decided to take a little walk around
Missoula in the morning turns out
there's no one here
no nannies and no rich kids so I can't
play that game can play like picnic
table park bench the park is completely
abandoned but it's fun still so you know
this but none of our viewers do every
year around this time I send a survey to
all of my friends and family I wonder if
all of you are getting nauseous that'll
be awesome my friends and family answer
that survey and then I put it online so
everybody can see the answers my butt
hurts Jesus this thing is not built for
my butt the problem is that the survey
is text-based so I can't actually send
it to you but there's no way I'm going
to break this tradition so this question
is one through six are the same as
they've always been and I already know
they answered all those questions so I'm
not going to ask you we start with
question 7 how long have you known Hank
and Katherine question 8 what do you
want from us
question 9 now what are you doing please
be as specific as possible because we
actually all want to know
question 10 how much longer do you think
you'll be doing it question 11 why are
you doing it question 12
what do you want to be doing question 13
what is next in your life question 14
how you doing question 15 what's the
best book you read this year question 16
describe a perfect day assuming that all
things come to an end how will humans go
extinct so how are you feeling about
kids these days in this space create
your own question and answer it
wrote some tastes better than any other
kind of food
what does them produce or taste like
here a cliche like a show to be what's
your least favorite part of any given
day you enjoy science fiction cheese
chocolate
what was your first concert where would
you live if you could live anywhere
would you rather invisibility or time
travel if you could start a business
that would be instantly successful what
kind of business would it be what's
wrong with the world and a final
question number 30 can I put the survey
on my webpage I didn't get the plane
then you need a rich kid this morning
but there is another game that I
sometimes like to play it's called go to
Barnes & Noble and see who's on the
young adult romance shelf lady lady lady
lady lady lady lady lady lady lady lady
John Green nothing wrong with that
that's great it's great you your mum
John it's right there in the middle
tales of love and romance no it's great
I think it's great really right there on
the end cap right in the middle tales of
love and romance I think it's great
really well done and I'll see you on
Monday